because he's a messenger of God because
no one knows the future in details
except except and there's many
prophecies M for example you will see
the Barefoot Arab man competing in build
to
buildings you know the Arab 50 years ago
like Dubai Saudi was a pure
desert yeah the toest building in the
world is in
Dubai understand Khalifa yeah so again
how these prophets orh
Muhammad who lived 1,400 years ago
prophesizing about something we can see
right now because he's a messenger of
God that's why Islam is not based upon
just emotion Islam is based upon
tangible
proofs that's why you know Islam is
about worshiping one God who is that God
Allah describ
himself Allah is one unique Allah is
self-sufficient everything's in need of
him is is not in need of nothing let me
yell you
he neither was
he there's nothing like to Allah Allah
is the Creator and we are the creation
you understand not like God become baby
like Christianity it doesn't make any
sense you understand so you know like I
said to you sister what happened soon or
later we're going to die how many people
left the house and never come back
that's the reality how many people want
sleep they they even wake up you know
regardless how you how old you are 16 18
20 see young all of us would die so we
have to prepare ourselves for for the
death that's what our Prophet Muhammad
said visit the graveyard why when you go
to the graveyard those people are inside
the graves they were like all of us here
they had many wishes maybe they had
houses they had families and all of that
now they Ins at the graves you know and
when you when you when you die there's
no need there's no way you're going to
come back this life this life
is for us to be tested understand so we
should utilize here and you know what
yes I need to worship God yes no problem
work you know look after yourself
there's no problem with that but this
life is a test God has a mercy out of
his Mercy create Paradise God has anger
and mighty out of his anger and mighty
he created the Hellfire but he gave all
of us a free will to choose if we're
going to follow his teaching or follow
the way of Satan what